und es gibt einschränkungen und es wird
wird weiter einschränkungen geben
und auch da noch mal aus eigener
betroffenheit mir muss keiner erzählen
dass kleinen selbstständigen und
handwerkern geht auch im gegensatz zu
vielen anderen die darüber reden habe
ich selbst erlebt man komme aus der
familie von einzelhändlern und
handwerkern ich weiß was es heißt wenn
kein kunde kommt oder wenn die
gewerbemieten nicht zu bezahlen ist weil
man nicht noch oben satz hat weiß ich
alles aber was heißt denn das jetzt dann
für die pandemie bekämpfung
wir lassen einfach weiter alles auf was
was wie die wollen wir das denn gegen
rächen wie viel tote sind uns denn jetzt
ganz konkret ein shoppingerlebnis wird
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren